the whole point of the meter surely
isn't it to hold the rich and powerful
to account
[Music]
that's a that's not like a nice you know
fairy
[Music]
tale hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm frances foster i'm constantin
kitchen and this is a show for you if
you want honest conversations with
fascinating people a brilliant guest we
have for you today he's one of america's
finest and most principal journalist
glenn greenwald welcome to trigonometry
i'm thrilled to be here we've been
working for a while for me to get here
and i'm glad it finally worked out and i
appreciate the invitation oh it's it's
great to have you on the show we're so
keen to speak with you glenn though we
try not to focus on the day-to-day
events and occurrences i know you cover
those as well but the question we really
wanted to start with
is kind of to ask you the broader
question which is what the hell is going
on with journalism
i think that you have to
begin with the premise that the trump
era radically transformed almost every
aspect of
american political and cultural life
which if you think about it is not that
difficult to understand why if large
sectors of the society convince
themselves that the person who has
risen to power in a country is really
this unprecedented threat never before
seen menace
to all good things in the world
essentially and often literally the kind
of return of like a hitler-like figure
it's gonna change
everything that you do in terms of how
you process the world the decisions you
make the things that you come to believe
aren't aren't justifiable
and i think that
number one there was a lot of true
believers who really did see trump in
that manner
and therefore their decisions and making
and behavior change very radically as a
result
but i also think that the this incentive
scheme arose
in which the people who fed that
paranoid belief were the ones who were
most rewarded they were most rewarded
not just financially although definitely
that as well
but with
more attention more positive feedback on
social media
those are very powerful incentives for
human beings uh to which journalists are
not even close to immune
and so once you
start looking at journalism not as this
profession that's designed to inform the
public regardless of
who it aggrandizes or or impedes but
instead has this kind of moral
obligation
to stop this profound threat where you
turn yourself into just nothing but
activists by definition
obviously it's going to radically
transform the work that's done under the
banner of journalism and i think that
more than anything is what happens
and let me ask you this because a lot of
people are just having watched the last
two minutes of you talking about what's
happened to the media might listen to
that and think well glenn is a massive
fan of donald trump and he's just upset
that other journalists didn't love him
as much as he does so how you know first
of all can you address that and also
just talk to us about what an actually a
good journalist would have done in the
trump era
yeah so you know
if you i mean i've been in journalism
for 15 years um
i've been largely associated with the
left not just in the us but also in
brazil where i do a lot of work my
husband is a member of congress with an
actual
socialist party
um
you know the biggest influence of my
political and journalistic outlook is
noam chomsky and before that if stone i
think it's a very hard case to make
given my views on individual
issues to claim that i'm somehow some
kind of a fan of donald trump of course
of course that's often
what's asserted though i don't really
think anyone actually believes that i
think my real split with the kind of
mainstream sector of the media and the
liberal left came
not because they actually think that i
love donald trump or i'm a fan of his
ideology i don't think anyone um who's
remotely sane actually thinks that
um the split came over the question of
whether you see trump as some kind of a
radical aberration from the american
political tradition or simply a cruder
and almost more candid reflection of it
and i'd say most journalists were in the
former category and i was definitely in
the latter i see trump way more as a
symptom of american pathologies
than as a cause or the prime author of
them
if i did see him like a kind of
hitler-esque figure
i would actually probably have been more
willing to
think and behave in the way that they
did
here in brazil for example i would never
say the jair bolsonaro the president of
brazil the far-right president is
anything like a hitler figure but he
definitely is a greater threat to
brazilian democracy than trump ever was
to american democracy for a whole bunch
of reasons principally leading with the
fact that brazilian democracy is only 35
years old not 235 years old
half the population lived under an
actual military dictatorship and
therefore its institutions are much more
fragile i always knew that in the us
there were these you know kind of
permanent power centers
like the intelligence community the
military-industrial complex wall street
whose existence is solely about
preserving status quo stability and
power and trump was never near strong
enough
to meaningfully challenge them the most
he ever did was kind of tweet some crazy
things
but if you look at the actual conduct of
his government it very much resembled
what came before him and what
has come after him
as well so i think the primary split in
how i see trump isn't about whether i
like him or not
it's about how much of a subversive
force i thought he was
in american politics and i actually
thought the ways in which he was
subversive and disruptive were largely
positive
um but mostly
what he did was just kind of continue
through negligence of nothing else how
america has been conducting itself
basically since the end of world war ii
and especially when it became the only
superpower with the fall of the soviet
union
and glenn it seems to me that the media
has just abandoned nuance they don't
they don't interested in annoyance
whether they're talking about trump
whether they're talking about biden we
saw that with the election of biden
what happened to balanced journalism
which analyzed both sides of the
argument
well as i said you know look if i
actually believed
that us democracy was imperiled by a
singular leader
and the movement behind him and he had
designs to impose
what we had always talked about as some
kind of a fascist
government or regime that was going to
put an end to democratic institutions
and democratic values
i would probably be willing to do things
to fight that
even under the guise of journalism
that under normal circumstances i'd be
unwilling to do because i would probably
decide that the threat and the
moral imperative to stop it
is so great that it outweighs the norms
and duties of the profession of
journalism
so i think that once you are begin
operating from this premise that you're
on the front lines fighting a fascistic
takeover of your country which is really
what
many of them either pretend to believe
or in fact believe i think the line
between those two things eventually
blurs
because if you pretend to believe
something long enough you ultimately
start believing it
if you really do believe that then
journalistic norms why would you mean it
would be almost immoral to be
constrained by those right because
you're talking about
warding off
fascism
so i think that delusion
you know beginning with the
the
you know contrived conspiracy theory
that putin had infiltrated
american institutions like straight out
of the 1950s like the cia labs of the
1950s that the kremlin had contaminated
american political life and converted
people into clandestine agents at the
highest levels of government
into then believing that trump was like
a couple of days from just like putting
racial minorities into camps
when you work yourself up into that kind
of frenzied mania
then i think it's almost rational to
start behaving the way that they behave
which is not caring if what you're
saying is true or false
not caring if you adhere to any kind of
journalistic ethics or norms doing
everything you can even if it means
lying and publishing falsehoods to stop
this fascistic threat which is why i say
i believe the crucial split is over who
sees trump that way and who doesn't
and what effect does that have on
society glenn when the media are trying
to essentially push a narrative they're
not there to investigate to challenge
and then to report back what effect does
that have on society but let's be fair
because america leads the world on this
on the globe as a whole yeah i mean it's
so fascinating to me that
corporate
media outlets and the employees who work
for them
love incessantly to talk about the
dangers of fake news and disinformation
and they love to lament the fact that
people now turn away from them and no
longer believe them and believe these
sources of information that they regard
as inferior to them or less reliable
than they are
and in the course of lamenting this
pathology which is a genuine problem
you need
a society if it's going to be healthy a
democracy it's going to be healthy to
have
sources of information that most people
in the society even if they have
different ideologies can more or less
trust to tell them what's going on in
the world and if you lose that you lose
a really important stabilizing force an
ability for people to even have
shared perceptions of
the facts and reality
in all the discussions about how that's
happening and how bad it is
they almost never stop and ask the
question why has that happened
because the answer is
they play a central role
in why people have lost faith and trust
in those institutions
of journalism that have long been
regarded as legitimate by most people
they were the ones who sold the country
the lies that led to the invasion of
iraq
they were the ones who glorified the
people who brought us the 2008 financial
crisis from which people continue to
suffer to this very day
and people are not dumb they understood
they saw for themselves that the media
was willing to do and say anything to
stop donald trump
and once you have this series of
episodes that justifiably and validly
cause a huge portion of the population
to no longer place their faith and trust
in established corporate media
institutions
of course they're gonna start looking
elsewhere
for their news
and i do regard that as genuinely tragic
even though i believe the people who are
doing that are are acting appropriately
i also don't trust those institutions i
regard it though
as as damaging because i do think
a healthy society needs
a kind of group of institutions you can
rely on and trust
and
part of my project
is not to try and destroy these
institutions but to try and rebuild
faith and trust in journalism by showing
that it can still be done
in a way that it can inspire confidence
among people who have differing
religious values political beliefs
ideologies and the like
and glenn what would you say to those
people who go look here's a reality the
media have always been lying to us
they've always been trying to pull the
wool over our eyes it's just now in 2016
and the age of the internet we are able
to see it for ourselves
there's definitely validity to that
argument um you know i
as you know you probably know before i
became a journalist i was working as a
lawyer
a constitutional lawyer and and i
started writing about politics at the
end of 2005 i just created a kind of
free blog
on what was called blogspot at the time
this free uh blogging
platform
from google
in large part because i was looking at
the
developments in the the wake of 9 11 and
the war on terror
and felt that the media was not only
ignoring really crucial
assaults on civil liberties but often
was lying about what was taking place
and the more i looked you know it was
the first time i paid attention as a
full-time job to politics and journalism
as opposed to law
the more i began realizing that this has
been a long standing problem throughout
the cold war
the cia partnered with
all of the major corporate institutions
media institutions in the united states
to disseminate propaganda they would
engineer coups and they would have time
magazine or the new york times call it
you know a popular revolution or a you
know blow against tyranny um
conversely when they had democratically
elected leaders they didn't like they
would have those media outlets call them
tyrants
and then hail the replacements or were
anointed by the us with no votes as
protectors of democracy so this
closeness between
the security state and large standing
corporate media outlets
has been going on again since the
security state was created at the end of
world war ii and as i said that's the
reason why
it wasn't
right-wing
media outlets that helped the bush
administration
sell the country on the iraq war it was
the liberal outlets like the new york
times
and the new yorker and the atlantic and
nbc news because those institutions
despite being more liberal on cultural
issues were completely inextricably
linked with and deferential to
the government and that created all
kinds of deceit and propaganda so it
isn't that it's a new problem
at all i've been writing about it long
before anyone dreamed that donald trump
could be president obviously many other
people before me were doing the same
i think that what happened in the trump
administration is that all of that went
on to steroids
um you know at the very least even
though the media often propagandized on
questions of safe foreign policy and
barely ever questioned the security
state when it came to the kind of
day-to-day trivial warfare between the
two primary political parties the
republicans and democrats they would at
least make an effort
to have a pretense of objectivity
between the two parties not to favor one
or the other and that i think is more
than anything what
that that one kind of
notion of fairness that they were
clinging to
ultimately even that got destroyed so
they just became open propaganda arms of
the democratic party
and engaged in open warfare against the
republican party all in the name of
stopping donald trump and and i think
that is what took that's what took what
was already clearly a systemic problem
but made it
a much much greater problem and a more
visible problem than ever before
so glenn what about now though because
look they got what they wanted joe biden
is president the the democrats are you
know free to do almost what whatever
they want uh you know the kids the kids
are still in cages but they don't have
to cover it and and all of that they're
not cages anymore they're detention
facilities that's correct of course they
are uh
and and so why are their brains still
broken they got trump out why can't they
just relax and start reporting the truth
now
well for one thing
if you look at
what has happened to them a lot of
people forget that before trump came
down that golden escalator with melania
in 2015 and now said he was running for
president
most of these media outlets were on the
verge of complete financial ruin
you can go back and find for example in
articles in 2014 and 2015 that msnbc was
on the verge of firing its entire
prime time lineup with the exception of
racial matter because nobody was
watching those shows and the new york
times
people really doubted whether they were
going to actually be able to have a
sustainable financial model
trump saved
almost the entire media industry
single-handedly ratings went through the
roof
um
enormous numbers of books were sold
people got very rich off
you know activism and warnings over
donald trump the aclu was laying off its
entire workforce basically in the obama
years no one wanted the eclu suing obama
on the grounds they was acting
unconstitutionally but then soon as you
know they position themselves as the
primary opponent to trump they they're
drowning in money
so they don't want he's a cash cow so
they don't want to you know go back to
just talking no one wants to hear about
joe biden
and that's why their audience is
disappearing
and
it's disappearing very quickly so
they're just desperate you know trying
to kind of pump life into this corpse
that is the trump presidency
but people know he's gone and so it's
not working
it is true that even though trump is no
longer in power there is his movement
that still has some degree of influence
i mean there's members of congress in
the senate who still espouses ideology
one of them is going to be the
republican nominee almost certainly in
2024 if trump himself as they're hoping
and praying on their knees on a daily
basis
runs again himself in 2024
so part of it is
just the profit model they need the
villain the scary monster right it's
like um you know if you have the game of
thrones you can't kill off cersei the
queen because who are you going to hate
and care about and be angry towards
that's kind of what trump is for
these media so they need to kind of prop
them up and keep them alive and convince
themselves that the threat is still
there
but also i think some of them again do
genuinely believe that there's this
fascist movement lurking in the united
states ready to take over at any moment
and the hysteria and mania and paranoia
and delusions and psychological and
anxiety disorders that govern their
brains
and have since 2016
really haven't gone anywhere and so you
listen to them and it does sound like
they think it's 2018 in part because
they want it to be and need it to be but
also in part because they still believe
that it really is
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you're not bad
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off of the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
but glenn doesn't that mean that we have
a media that is no longer fit for
purpose the whole point of the media
surely isn't it to hold the rich and
powerful to account
that's a that's not like a nice you know
fairy tale i mean
you know again look like the reality is
the the media like you know 30 years ago
when we talked about the media we were
only talking about gigantic corporations
that could afford
you know cameras and studios and and
satellites and network fees
or
families that had long owned printing
presses and gigantic newsrooms that
employed hundreds if not thousands of
reporters and editors and and the like
so obviously it's long been the wealthy
that have been powerful that have
controlled and owned the media and so
the media has largely served the purpose
for the last say 30 to 40 years
of serving the interest of of power
centers before that
if you go back kind of before the
corporatization of the media which for
me began in say the 50s and 60s
for the first half of the 20th century
journalism really was this like outsider
profession
they mostly came from working class
backgrounds they didn't make much money
they were big union activists they all
had labor you know
they all had uh newspaper guilds
um
and they felt like outsiders they didn't
go to school with the powerful and rich
people they were covering they hated
those people like they had the outsider
mentality
and it really started changing when
television became popular and we started
having multi-millionaire news anchors
and people aspiring to be rich and
famous in journalism and suddenly they
were in the same social circles as the
rich and powerful and then the owners of
those
outlets were corporate conglomerates who
obviously don't want any disruptions to
the status quo
and prevailing ruling class and and so i
think it became much more an agent of
preservation of power i think the
internet though
is potentially a genuine threat to that
hegemonic order and it's the reason why
whenever an independent outlet
starts to succeed
the way first social media did twitter
youtube facebook they instantly started
agitating for controls on those
platforms don't let people say this kick
them off if they say that
and now that there are other outlets
that are
specifically created to avoid the kind
of
captivity to censorship demands that big
tech monopolies have succumbed to
they are obviously waging war against
any of those that start to have an
influence you saw that yesterday with
the news that i and
seven or eight other people including
former presidential candidate and
congresswoman phil scabbard went to
rumble a kind of youtube competitor that
is designed to ensure free speech unlike
youtube does
same when i quit the intercept and went
to sub stack and started having a big
audience there any platform that they
can't control
that is used that that is empowered by
the internet so you don't need any more
gigantic printing press to reach
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people you just need an internet
connection
um even to produce television shows now
basically you can do that with the
technology as we're doing right this
moment
you know that's why they're waging so
much such a war of
you know defamation and smear campaigns
because they do believe correctly
that the internet is finally fulfilling
its purpose
of providing a way for human beings to
emancipate themselves from the from
control of centralized media and
political power
and that for me is you know the most
important war there is i see this no
work i did with edward snowden 2013
about whether we're going to have a free
internet or the internet will be a
weapon of coercion and control and i
obviously see that as the same cause now
and fighting against online censorship
and glenn just coming back because one
of the things we've addressed with the
mainstream media is obviously the bias
and that's been a big factor in the last
few years but it seems to me like
there's also another thing that has
happened and i don't know whether
they're related or not tell me what you
think about this which is the media has
not only been slanted or elements of it
have been but it's also lost its
explanatory power even if you watch a
relatively objective reporting on say
like we we're in london right uh and and
a few a few minutes walk from here uh a
few years ago a terrorist stabbed a
number of people to death on on london
bridge now if you watched a report about
that you would almost certainly not
understand what motivated him who were
the people who supported him what drove
him to do it where he came from what the
movement that he represents is like it
doesn't give you the context that's
sufficient to actually understand
what's going on
how is that is that something that's
always been there or is that a new
development as well
yeah i absolutely think that that is
becoming the way that journalists behave
is that they see they kind of look like
i think that elite liberal culture
by which i just mean say the highly
educated professional classes who tend
to congregate in
large cities and and capitals
obviously in your country in london and
in the united states of new york and
washington and san francisco and los
angeles
do genuinely see themselves as this kind
of
class of
uh
nobles you know this kind of enlightened
class
who cannot trust
the rabble
to make good decisions on their own that
you can't just give them information and
leave it to them to decide for example
that terrorist attack that you're
talking about
you can describe what the motives were
right it was uh
i don't i don't know all the details of
the case you're describing so just using
this hypothetically you could say
it's this the person who did this attack
is a muslim he's a muslim extremist he's
an extremist both in his religious
convictions and in his political
convictions
um he did it partly because he hates the
permissive social mores of the united
kingdom
and western culture he also did it in
part because of anger at his perception
that western countries are interfering
in the muslim part of the world by
propping up dictators
and bombing innocent men women and
children
and then you leave it to the public to
decide how to evaluate that is the
threat that
this religion has not gone through
reformation
and therefore is actually a threat in
and of itself islam
is it that they don't they're not
compatible with western values
and can't integrate or assimilate or is
it that we're actually sowing the seeds
of our own
attacks through
the constant attempt to try and control
and interfere in and invade their part
of the world and take their resources
and that it's what the cia calls
blowback it's probably a combination of
all of those things in different cases
and then you can evaluate
what policies do i want to support to
stop that what do i think but the
journalist class doesn't trust people to
make those decisions for themselves
because they see them
as primitive and ignorant
tragedites
and therefore need to be led and guided
to how to think and sometimes that means
deceiving them
one of the most you know interesting
things i think is the admissions on at
least two occasions over the last year
during the covet pandemic
by dr falchi the lead scientist in the
united states that at least on two
occasions he purposely misled the
country
thinking it was for everyone's own good
not to know the truth once when he told
everybody not to wear
masks um
presumably because
he
wanted to make sure that masks were for
healthcare professionals and so instead
of admitting the truth he told them mass
don't work
and then
who knows how many people went out onto
the street without masks and picked up
covet and died
but then on another occasion he admitted
even more clearly when he was always
asked what percentage of the population
needs to be infected for us to reach
hurt immunity he admitted that he lied
based on polling data about what the
country was willing to hear that he
lowered it to 65 when he really believed
it was 75 or 80
because he didn't think people were
ready to hear the truth that is the
mentality of somebody who believes that
they are so enlightened that their lives
are noblized
and i think this has become a common
uh
view of the educated classes in western
democracies and the thing is
when you have contempt for people
and you condescend to them
and you show them that you believe that
they're ignorant
and inferior
they know that they feel that
and the only reaction that that will
produce in any healthy human being
is to make those people who are being
judged that way feel contempt for
the authorities and institutions of
power who are expressing that for them
and i think you see this over and over
and over
i know here in brazil a big reason why
bolsonaro was elected in a country that
four consecutive elections had elected a
center-left or even left-wing party the
workers party of lula dasoba
was because the institutions that they
hate kept telling them they couldn't do
it
i think following british politics a big
reason why brexit passed
is because
the
mavens of
elite liberal discourse the oxbridge
crowd in london were telling them
you can't vote for brexit and it was a
big [ __ ] you and they said i'm gonna
vote for brexit obviously the trump the
election of trump has similar overtones
a lot of people who twice voted for
obama
voted for trump obviously something was
going on there besides ideology
so i think this
kind of um
contempt that the elite class has for
those that they regard as inferior to
them is driving a huge part of these
dynamics and you say it's driving a huge
part of these dynamics glenn it almost
seems like the same parallel thing is
happening with
the left
and particularly the left political
parties labor in our countries democrats
in yours
yeah um i think you know you see this
dynamic playing out
in particularly liberal
uh precincts because in the united
states
the democratic party went from being the
party of
labor and workers and minorities as it
was primarily constituted in the 50s 60s
and 70s
and into the 80s and then with bill
clinton he had an explicit project
to remake the democratic party
into a party that would serve corporate
interests
so that they weren't out spent any
longer by the republican party so that
the power centers weren't opposed to
them
a very similar trajectory with the labor
party obviously under tony blair i'm
nodding vigorously as you say that glenn
i was just thinking that it sounds
exactly like tony blair here in the uk i
mean tony blair and bill clinton are you
know in my view political twins and
you know the victories that each of them
had as unlikely skilled politicians
you know me people think that that was
the only path that that should be taken
and it turned out you know at least in
the us that
that kind of politics drove
the working class out of
the
precincts of the democratic party and
obviously labor currently has a huge
difficulty
even with the incredibly charismatic and
earthly circular star
[Laughter]
you know winning in
northern industrialized you know
working-class um
constituencies for the same reason that
if you make this party you the reason
why joe biden won people don't really
understand this is you know for all the
talk about how trump is like a white
nationalist and a racist
and hates
latinos his percentage of the vote among
racial minorities especially latinos
increased significantly it increased in
2016 as compared to previous republican
nominees but then increased even more
in 2020 the reason
donald trump lost and joe biden won
barely
is because a lot of wealthy suburbanites
white professional college educated
suburbanites who have long voted
republican kind of a mitt romney type
republican found donald trump to crude
and voted for joe biden so the democrats
became even more of this like
professionalized
you know highly educated
um
mid to upper class party
um and i think you see the same thing
happening you know to the labor party
they have no way out of
you know the alienation that they have
bred among working-class voters and so
they're just kind of trying to
desperately lean into a strategy that
says well we'll just you know make
ourselves more amenable to the kind of
people who have traditionally voted for
tories and it's failing in the uk and
it's failing in in the united states
because
you cannot win
as a party that is
you know viewed as an elitist party and
i think both the
starmer wing the blairites of labor and
the clintonites and the liberals and
obamas and bidens of the democratic
party are both perceived that way
correctly and accurately
and
it's amazing i'd never put the two
together what happened to the media and
what happened to the left
do you think there's any way back for
either either the political institution
of of the left
and the media itself do you think
there's any way to save these two
political the the movement and the media
or do you think we need to start again
we need to abolish these things or let
them crumble and rebuild as it were
you know i think the problem is that it
becomes a self-perpetuating cycle
because in the united states what has
happened is you know in 2016
there was an impressive left-lane
movement for the first time in i would
say several decades in the united states
it wasn't a hard left movement
um
but it was a left-ish movement that
coalesced around bernie sanders
i think a lot of it came from the fact
that the 2008 financial crisis and the
neo-liberal policies of the democratic
party
had caused a huge an entire generation
of people
to lose all hope for the future they
live with their parents until they're 30
or older in larger percentages than any
time since the great depression
um
they can't get married until they're in
their mid-30s and even then with great
difficulty both parents have to work
outside the house it's very hard to
raise a child that way
um
and they're angry and they became kind
of you know amenable for the first time
to
a kind of left-wing politics that railed
against big finance globalism
big tech wall street
and
bernie sanders came very close to
beating
hillary clinton in 2016. had the dnc not
cheated in the ways that wikileaks
revealed
he probably would have beaten her which
is you know he started off as this you
know
very obscure old brooklyn jew who wasn't
even a member of the democratic party no
obviously no one thought he could get
anywhere close to taking down
the mammoth clinton machine
that was funded by billionaires and had
demonstrated this huge centralized power
for decades was almost invulnerable and
yet he almost beat her
but and that was a kind of sign that
left-wing politics could really
revitalize
um
and then obviously the victory by people
like alexander ocasio-cortez against the
long-term
democratic kind of standard you know
back room
lobbyist-funded politician
fed that perception but then what
happened was the fear
that contaminated the left over donald
trump
made the left rush into the arms of the
democratic party so there's almost no
distance any longer between the
democrats
and the left
i see a lot of that at least with kind
of i mean i would say like one of the
most prominent left-wing
you know voices in in the uk is let's
like say owen jones
someone who has like a decent sized
platform and at the end of the day you
know even if it's this like blair-right
candidate as the one who just ran joe
cox's sister
there he is saying no matter what you
have to vote for you have to vote labor
even though
what's amazing to me about that is the
democratic party has made clear that it
despises the american left it humiliated
bernie sanders and his humiliated aoc
they just humiliated bernie sanders
totally gratuitously when one of his
closest allies ran for congress
and for no reason other than a desire to
show how much they hate the lap they
intervened in that race and poured
millions and millions of dollars into
helping her opponent win and they
succeeded
just like
the blair right wing of the labor party
made very clear that they would rather
sabotage jeremy corbyn and lose
to theresa may or boris johnson than win
with jeremy corbyn no matter how much
the labor rights or the democrats show
that they despise the left and are going
to spit in their face and every chance
they get
both the british left and the american
left remain incredibly subservient it's
almost like a very uncomfortable s m
ritual to watch like the more
they're humiliated and the more contempt
is shown for them the more submissive
they get
so i barely see
like a left-wing movement in the uk or
the us separate and apart from the labor
part establishment labor party or the
democratic party and i also see the
media getting worse
so
that's why the only thing that interests
me
are
creating new platforms and new
institutions
that are
constituted by other
ways of thinking about the world beyond
traditional liberal versus conservative
or left versus right
ideological categories that to me are
becoming increasingly archaic and
ossified
i just think rebuilding competing
institutions is the only prospect that
um is a cause for any optimism at all
hey constantin are you crypto curious i
told you this sort of behavior is
illegal in my country if you've thought
about entering the world of
cryptocurrency but feel a little too
overwhelmed coinbase makes learning to
buy and sell simple coinbase is a
trusted and easy to use platform to buy
sell and spend crypto currencies they
support the most popular digital
currencies on the market and make them
accessible to everyone in russia we have
sputnik coin it will take you to the
moon but you might not come back okay
mate cryptocurrency might feel like a
secret or exclusive club but coinbase
believes that everyone everywhere should
be able to get in the door whether
you've been trading for years or just
getting started coinbase can help real
men don't ask for help and by real men i
mean russians
great coinbase offer portfolio
management and protection learning
resources and a mobile app so you can
trade securely and monitor your crypto
all in one place whether you're looking
to diversify just getting started or
searching for a better way to access
crypto markets start today with coinbase
for a limited time new users can get
five euros in free bitcoin when you sign
up today at coinbase.com forward slash
trigger sign up at coinbase.com forward
slash trigger for five euros in free
bitcoin this offer is for a limited time
only so be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com
forward slash trigger if you're a real
man
it's interesting that you make that
point because one of the of the things
that we should all acknowledge i suppose
is you've built obviously a very
successful career as an independent
journalist now your sub stack is huge
you've got a huge following on twitter
etc etc you're now on rumble and we
ourselves you know we're we're doing
very well with our show on youtube and
elsewhere as kind of independent
journalists stroke commentators all
three of us
but there is something to be said for
big media corporations their ability to
do investigative journalism by employing
lots of people to sift through
billions of pages of documents and and
things like that like we do need some
form of corporate media don't we
well
yes and no so
you're right i mean i've always
maintained my status as an independent
journalist
but in the most important
reporting i've done in my career i've
worked with large institutions i
probably wouldn't have been able to do
this note in reporting had i not
been able to lure the guardian into
doing it with me
i needed the teams of editors and fact
checkers and lawyers and money that only
a big institution like that
could provide
i couldn't have reported on a gigantic
archive of that technical complexity
alone i probably would have been
prosecuted had i just been off on my own
i think a big reason why julian assange
is in prison
and i'm not is because he hasn't ever
really aligned himself that way with
large corporate institutions when i did
my reporting here in brazil
um over the last couple of years that
ended up freeing lula da silva and and
you know ushering in a lot of changes in
brazilian politics and a lot of reform
not only did i have the intercept brazil
that i had created that was funded by a
billionaire i also also ended up
partnering on purpose with the largest
newspaper in brazil and also the largest
news weekly
in brazil
because not only do they need the
financial resources that they can
provide that you know expertise that
journalists have that i don't have um
technologists to work with you to
decipher the material but then also
you know kind of the army of lawyers and
and
voices you need if you're going to
battle the government i absolutely agree
with you you do need resources and
institutional power
in order to do that kind of reporting
and that's why i say i i don't
you know my mission my project is not to
destroy the model of media i believe in
journalism a lot
um
but it's only worthwhile if it's
actually fulfilling its function
and so what i've always tried to do was
balance that independence that you
talked about
with
kind of looking at those institutions as
something that i use and exploit
rather than
kind of submit myself to
um
you know i
worked with the guardian and then left
um and i always kept control of the
archive and never gave it to them
um i did similar things with the brazil
reporting so i think it's a balance um
but i also think that
the more people lose faith and trust in
the media the more possible it's going
to become to build
independent alternatives that do have
real funding whether because
the public supports it so much that you
can generate enough revenue to build it
into a real institution
you can attract funders who
also see the same things that we're
talking about and have a lot of
resources
all of which i think are possible so
creating a new space in media
i think is is crucial but you're right
it can't just be
you know some youtubers over here
monetizing their audience and making a
nice living or a single sub stacker over
here who's living well
you do sometimes need
large teams in order to take on powerful
institutions
and let me just push back on the idea
about you know people
creating content from themselves
building these these new institutions as
it were let's look at the example of
parlor
let's look at what the powers that be
did to parlor they essentially pulled
the plug
i mean they can do that to any of us
we're all in and we're you know
we're all at the behest of big tech
yeah i mean that is a crucial question
um
i actually you know it's funny i was on
fox last night and i made the point that
i think the destruction of parlor is one
of the most overlooked stories of the
last year if not the single most
overlooked in terms of
what it really showed the only thing i
would compare it to is the decision by
facebook and twitter to ban
any reporting on the hunter biden
archive in the weeks absolutely that was
absolutely extraordinary but that got
some attention the destruction of
parliament happened so quickly and it
was in the wake of the january 6th
right that a lot of people overlooked it
but what people forget is that
you know after january 6
when facebook and twitter
remove donald trump from the internet
basically
even as world leaders objected including
world leaders who
never had any good things to say about
trump angela merkel found it alarming
emmanuel macron did too
the president of mexico was very
eloquent in denouncing the dangers
people migrated to parlor because they
wanted a place where you could be free
of that just ability a big text just zap
even the elected president of the most
powerful country in the world off the
internet it's incredibly chilling and
parlor became such a success
that it was the single most downloaded
app on apple and google play stores more
than facebook more than instagram more
than uh tik tok
more than anything
it was the most popular app that people
were downloading and using
and aoc and a bunch of other democratic
politicians went on to twitter
and said
uh google and apple how can you allow a
platform like this
that is enabling
insurrection and right-wing violence on
your stores
and then obviously knowing that the
democratic party was about to take over
all branches of government when apple
and google heard that they responded
they kicked parlor off their store so
you couldn't download it anymore and
then aoc went back on twitter and said
thank you apple and google now what
about you amazon why are you still
hosting
parlor on your web service and then
amazon did what google and apple did
which was obeyed the demand and kicked
parlor off and within 48 hours
this union of big tech monopolies and
the democratic party destroyed the most
single popular app that people were
using to communicate with one another on
the planet
so the question you ask is a very
important one
and all i can tell you is that obviously
alternative outlets like sub stack like
rumble
like others like that have watched that
and
realized that they need to come up with
technical solutions to insulate
themselves from
those kind of attacks so they're not
dependent on amazon and apple and google
that they can build their own
technological infrastructure that
immunizes them
from the ability of outside forces to
destroy them if they get too powerful
and too successful the way parlor did
obviously there are a lot of people like
jack dorsey the founder and ceo of
twitter long may he rain clint
long may he reign especially because he
has now become probably the single most
important voice advocating for the need
for
blockchain and
crypto technologies which will
decentralize everything turn them into
protocols so that you can no longer even
if you want to
pull down content because people are
using their own personal protocols that
aren't dependent on anyone else i think
that's a little ways away it has its own
questions and problems
but absolutely technological solutions
to prevent
the kind of thing we saw with parlor but
also with the censorship of the hunter
biden reporting are of the highest and
most urgent priority
glenn i wasn't going to ask you this uh
but i think i ought to do you think that
because i couldn't get i couldn't get
why people weren't getting you're the
first person i've ever heard say what
you've just said which is what i said
the moment the morning the hunter
biden's story was treated in the way
that it was treated i walked into this
very room and i said to the guys here
this is the biggest story of the year
and and everybody them and everybody
else kind of looked at me like
what are you talking about
was that election interference in your
opinion
i mean a zillion times more than
whatever they claim russia did
i mean think about it
this reporting came from
the oldest newspaper
in the united states the new york post
founded by one of the founding fathers
of the united states alexander hamilton
and yes it's murdoch own and yes it's
you know tabloid-ish but it also is a
real newspaper and those documents were
absolutely authentic yeah what bothered
me the most was the way they justified
the way big tech justified
when i say ban i mean ban like if you
try to post a link to those stories on
twitter
it wouldn't let you it would just say
that's an invalid link even if you
wanted to dm somebody and speak
privately to them and show it to them
you couldn't even post it there
facebook announced through a democratic
party operative who had spent 20 years
working for democratic party politicians
and then went to facebook that's
incredibly who they got to announce
that they were going to algorithmically
suppress the story pending what they
said was going to be a fact check to
make sure the documents were genuine of
course that fact check never came
because the documents were so facebook
blocked the story from spreading twitter
banned it completely
i think the reason that um
there wasn't a greater reaction is
because the dominant sector of the media
completely supported
that censorship
which
is mind-blowing
i mean imagine if you're an
authoritarian leader of a country or
you're an authoritarian oligarch
and someone says to you like obviously
it can't happen but like if a genie came
and granted you like one wish what would
be your greatest wish you would say
my greatest wish is that journalists
wouldn't oppose me but would instead
become the leading advocates for
authoritarian and authoritarianism and
censorship right like of course that
would never happen journalists would
never become the leading advocates of
censorship by their nature they don't
want censorship
but somehow in the united states that's
exactly what has happened journalists
are by far the primary and most vocal
and relentless advocates and agitators
for big tech censorship and they were
thrilled
that that reporting was censored because
they were petrified about donald trump
winning the election and all they cared
about was making sure he loses even if
it meant doing censoring and suppressing
legitimate reporting but what people
also forget is the way that all got
justified was that 50 former members of
the intelligence community including
former
directors of the cia
invented out of
the out of thin air the lie
that those documents were the byproduct
of russian disinformation so that phrase
russian disinformation had two claims to
it number one that those documents came
from the russians and number two that
they were fake that they were
inauthentic forged
both of those claims were absolute lies
but every media outlet including the
intercept which i co-founded in 2014 to
challenge the intelligence community not
to serve them
publish that lie that these documents
were
a russian disinformation to justify not
covering them and that was the
uh so it wasn't just that big tech
interfered in the election it was that
the cia did as well interfered in our
domestic politics and prevented who
knows how many millions of people
from hearing about you know obviously
it's no one cares if hunter biden is a
drug addict or hiring prostitutes
but the stories that were relevant were
the fact that he was pursuing deals in
places like the ukraine and ukraine and
china
that
the documents suggest included his
father in profit participation deals
which obviously raised real ethical
questions about the presidential front
runner in a really close election
it is a very high likelihood we'll never
be able to prove it
that suppressing that story by the
millions
swung the outcome of the election and
it was a joint effort by the cia the
liberal sector of the media and big tech
that was the coalition of power
that engaged in brute censorship
in order to manipulate the outcome of
the election as i said a zillion times
more worrisome than whatever they claim
russia did even if you
accept everything they say about russia
was true
right so glenn we've got this problem
with big tech
how do you solve it do you think that we
should be treated as monopolies and
effectively broken up
i do
um
they are clearly monopolies i don't
think twitter is a monopoly but facebook
google apple and amazon those four
companies in particular are classic
monopolies in violation of anti-trust
laws
i'm actually there's a
subcommittee in congress
called the house subcommittee on
antitrust and
other things i forget but they have
jurisdiction over that question
and it's obviously led by the democrats
since they're the majority party and
they issued a very
impressive scholarly and comprehensive
450 page report
saying concluding that these four
companies are classic monopolies of
violation of the anti-trust laws and
proposing a series of measures including
breaking them up
the problem is these companies are so
rich
that they fund both parties
that they haven't been able to generate
the support necessary to do that
and what's particularly bothersome is
you have all these you know right-wing
politicians like republican house
members who love to go on fox news or
oan or newsmax or social media
and
denounce big tech and say big tech
tyranny and all of that
but at the end of the day they're
getting funded by the lobbyists for
those companies they talk a big game but
they won't support
these measures to break up these
companies there are some republicans who
are now doing it they just got past the
point where they believe democracy can
withstand this manipulation so hopefully
and part of my project is to try and
bring the right and the left together in
their common
hatred for these companies and and
that's what antitrust laws are for
because that's the only way you can deal
with monopolies by definition is you
can't compete with them that's what
makes them a monopoly
i agree with you glenn and look this is
why this stupid left versus right game
is so fruitless and pointless because
we're ignoring the real issue which is
essentially the big tech companies now
to a large extent decide who gets
elected and that should worry us a lot
more than jeremy corbyn's giving money
away or boris johnson delivering or not
delivering brexit or whatever else no we
could talk for hours but we've got to
let you go so before we do a couple of
questions for our local supporters let
us ask you our final question which is
as always what is the one thing we're
not talking about that we really should
be
um you know i knew you were going to ask
that because i've seen you ask that
before
um so i should have had an answer ready
so i didn't have to do all the
stammering and stuttering that i'm still
obviously doing right now to give myself
time to think about what the answer
might want to be
um you know i think
that when at least when it comes to us
politics and and
also even british politics that tends to
be a part of this
one of the things that seems to find
ongoing bipartisan consensus is the idea
that these western powers nato powers
should continue to play this role in the
world
of
operating these gigantic militaries and
trying to control the rest of the world
through these gigantic expenditures that
as i said earlier
often are what lead to people hating our
countries and our governments we bomb
places we kill them and with afghanistan
now unraveling and people realizing that
20 years of occupation of afghanistan
at huge expense to the countries that
did it including yours and and and mine
basically accomplished nothing as the
taliban now just take over the country
as though it and as none of it ever
happened
and it does seem to be the kind of
policy that
evades any kind of debate because it is
supported by both the establishment
wings of say in your country labor and
and conservative party and in the united
states the republican democrats so i
think it's time you know china just
produced this kind of trolling mocking
video
about how they only spent 800 billion
dollars to create this incredibly
efficient
comprehensive high-speed
rail system that obviously serves the
chinese you can go travel immense
distances from one city to another in a
very short period of time
um and it's very environmentally
friendly as well
while the u.s spent trillions of dollars
in a 20-year war in afghanistan and the
10-year war in iraq that produced no
benefits for the american people and i
think
those kinds of debates are ones that you
know we probably should be having a lot
more of
glenn it has been an absolute pleasure
if people want to find you online where
would be the best place for that
i write at sub stock um so you can find
me there doing my journalism obviously
i'm an active user of twitter um and
then i just this week i have moved
my video platform to rumble
um
because it's a free speech platform and
you can find my video journalism there
fantastic glenn thanks so much for
coming on uh we're gonna do a couple of
quick questions for locals in a second
but in the meantime thank you all for
tuning in watching and listening we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7 p.m uk time which is 2
p.m eastern take care and see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below